okay all right we'll get started here so
thanks again for everybody for coming
out ah I'm one of the co-organizers oh
sorry oh I'm one of the co-organizers
you'll see Ben around he was one
downstairs greeting people I work here
at TD Ameritrade and that Ben works for
continuum so anybody that's used a
anaconda and like to acknowledge several
different coops obviously none focus PI
data TD Ameritrade letting us use this
space also in our spark for helping us
to know communicate and also Midas for
sponsoring the food today and then a
couple important points always is
emergency exists for those who are new
there's an exit right here and obviously
there's an exit 2 right outside the
doors over here so don't take the
elevators there's a fire also we're
looking for speakers looking for
sponsors if there's any companies that
want to sponsor food in the future and
also provide feedback to either been our
eyes either through the meetup group or
just feel free to stick around and say
you know you guys are being great
expense to a certain group or we like
what you guys are doing right so
positive negative feedback we welcome
that also check out our github page so
everything that we have here we're going
to ask groups to send us hopefully
that's deck that can be recirculated but
if you go go there you can clone it you
can grab any of the talk slides also
please unless you have quick questions
hold them to the end so that for the
sake of time and again we're in a board
space so please clean up after
yourselves
there's garbage cans over by where the
food was because we're fairly known a
new group we do have our code of conduct
which I will read just to reinforce so
business short version so paw data is
dedicated to providing a harassment free
meeting experience for everyone
regardless of gender sexual orientation
gender identity and expression
disability physical appearance body size
race or religion we do not tolerate
harassment of meeting participants in
any form all communications should be
appropriate for a professional audience
including people of many different
backgrounds sexual language and imagery
is not appropriate for any of our made
up events
ah be kind to others do not insult if
we're done put down other people put
down other attendees behave
professionally when remember that
harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for pie data and identity attendees
violating these rules they be asked to
leave the meetup at the sole discretion
of the meetup organizers but thank you
for helping us make this a welcoming in
from the environment and as I'd like to
do to help people meet other folks is a
quick icebreaker
so think about your favorite fruit and
your least favorite fruit okay
you're left with your favorite food is
yeah
[Music]
alright and we're back we are back so
hopefully everybody here can at least
say that they repent somebody asked to
meet up right you know and hopefully you
introduce yourself and not just what
your favorite fruit is you're the guy
that likes apples is I think not that
there's anything wrong with that one of
the other things we like this mention is
you know some sort of data science
teasing of the month so this this month
we read that deep mind open sources
package called sonnet which I guess
helps you more easily build a neural
network kind of a class-based way of
doing in verses attention so but by the
way my torch already did that before and
they had dynamic computational grass
just to say and one other thing is that
we reached out to our friends at
O'Reilly and they said that if you tweet
us at PI data and our burn we will
direct message you back for one of these
free books that you can you can grab so
we'll send you the link to go get it
so tweet us at PI data annarbor okay so
if you want to grab one of these six
free ebooks w and also just a quick
question so my buddy over in the MSU in
Sebastian Raska who is a now Amazon
best-selling author of Python machine
learning
he's going to be giving a talk sometime
in the next few months so we're going to
work with Dan over here and here's an ml
group to get a Sebastian over here and
he has a question of people's
familiarity so by a show of hands who
has used sake learned before okay a
large majority of the group so hopefully
he's going to come in and do a workshop
with it would that be useful I'm going
to go through you know that that
pipelines we did a talk recently at Syfy
that was well received with Audrey s
Mueller and then I had a request from I
think his name was Chuck Anderson
there you go to to mention that a Chuck
scope of the Michigan times on users
group as they meet up the first Thursday
of every month is at 7 p.m.
over at a Washington Community College
so
hindi nether some other experts yeah
yeah fine Chuck yeah and then so with
that I'd like to introduce our speaker
for tonight so this is Drew medaka from
so he drew this a quantum Bloomberg but
prior to that he did his undergrad here
at the University of Michigan in the
mathematics right applied mathematics
and then afterwards he followed that up
with a degree in mathematical finance
over in Boston and then now he worked at
Bloomberg as a quant but he would been
chatting all day about that he's doing
everything whether it's research quanta
data visualization which is what he's
gonna talk about today yeah and so what
I'm going to flip this over to Drew and
shut up Dixon here ok thank you do you
have that mic on nope everyone in the
back hear me perfect okay okay let's go
presentation mode all right so everyone
thanks for spending this beautiful
evening with me I'm margin with you this
evening with me so today I'm going to
talk about BQ plot
it's a library we developed within our
group that one research group that's
from that's built for Jupiter so it
really is leveraging many different
aspects of Jupiter and using it to
enhance different aspects of a plotting
library you know so just to going to go
over it on what I mean yet pretty much
everyone knows is the Python
visualization landscape is landscape is
growing a bit too quickly just in the
last three I think the last year three
of these were new so why why learn the Q
plot well mostly because DQ plot is that
is
go for interaction don't work you can
build something like The Wealth of
Nations with just 19 lines of Python
code this doesn't really show but you
essentially you can build you can build
an entire nate silver like map which
shows the which shows all the results of
the u.s. elections with just eight lines
of Python code and make it fully
interactive no problem at all that's
that's definitely so what we we try to
leverage is really the interactivity and
the Jupiter notebook enables us through
the iPad widgets infrastructure to
really make it super easy to do all of
this so just a show of hands who's heard
of the iPad widgets not that cool so
guess that I have to go to the jupiter
notebook okay so you know is for the
people who haven't the a beverages are
way for the are set of pipes a set of
JavaScript objects that communicate
directly with the Python they have a set
of trade lists or attributes that can be
listened to so essentially you can build
something like a slider and that diet do
a Python function we extend that to a
grammar of graphics based blotting
libraries so that really enables us to
gain you know really great interactivity
and visualizations from d3.js so right
so yeah so basically we it's a we have
given that we've done this given that
we've exposed d3 through a Python
interface actually and every app and we
use the equity which is infrastructure
every element of our chart every blood
every scatter point is actually a web
element it's typically an SVG element so
that means that we can listen to all the
different aspects that all the different
we can bind Python functions to all the
different event handlers we can
associate listeners to different things
we can change plots after they've been
rendered so basically with just a few
lines of 500 your your Python chart
becomes a full scale web application you
don't know JavaScript
you don't read any complicated callbacks
there's very minimal set of code and the
Python and JavaScript communicate life
and are constantly aware of changes on
either side okay so before I go into the
details I would prefer to show all of
this in examples so how about we
although we go directly to do a live
demo okay so so right so BQ plot it's
it's it's a so before we start at the DQ
plot is first and foremost a plotting
library so if you if you define a set of
data it supports a map while if types
types and tax keep in mind we don't
support all of the things we probably
don't even want to wonder if you look
obviously we're going to do okay sure
I can sing into that so if we if we do
PLT lot it's going to generate a plot
for you the cool thing is this isn't
that this isn't a static image this is
actually a full-blown web application so
you can zoom into it you can reset you
can save the plot which will download it
as a PNG so already just just saying the
LTH show already changes the paradigm so
the cool thing is since everything
that's returned by binky plot is an
object you can modify it after the fact
so if you define a figure you can say
generate a scatter plot for me it's
going to do that for you you can we show
that so you can have different views
into the same model if you go into the
JavaScript kind of paradigm so like I
said every element of a DQ block chart
is an interactive widget I mean the X of
is the Y of this the color everything is
a widget you can change that directly so
here if I'm so I define this as a
scatterplot if I say change the Y so now
I'm going to give it some other random
set of numbers that's going to change
the original
I can do that again that's going to
change it again the entire chart is an
interactive widget it does not just the
Y values you can change the colors
that's going to change that after the
fact you can change you can change the
marker so if that's a view based thing
you see you get diamonds the cool thing
about DQ plot the reason we the reason
we saw power in it is basically you can
just say you define a Python function
like this say foo and you do something
in it what you can do is you can bind
this since again we work on the paradigm
of triplets I don't know how many people
have heard of tables you can say that
for the scatter plot observe observe the
Y attribute so you can make this color
you can make this marker you can make
this whatever you want and bind the
function food to that so once you do
that you can say set enable move to be
true or some property like that and
essentially this scatter plot is now a
full-blown web application and when you
change the Y value so by moving the
scatter plot that calls the Python
function foo so so when you moved it is
decide to print that but that's because
I'm printing I'm that's because that's
what my function is doing right but if I
if I do something else so say I say
print this print what's being passed to
me and then I read and I read it at that
that's going to change what what's being
printed you see now it's going to print
all the data that's being passed so in
this case the or the owner of the change
the new data and the old data so
basically it gives you it gives you a
state and it tells you what attribute
was changed so the function can also be
changed after the fact and again this is
all on the Python side now if you have a
script at all I'm actually talking to
Python
yeah the Java Script is not like drugs
no we're just lending it both sides the
Python is triggered
oh yeah real handy it's associated with
the Python kernel through the magic of
trade lists and other widgets when the
worst Craig let's trace faithless is a
Python is a is a pretty big Python
library essentially traceless is the
mechanism to do something like observe
what I buy widgets does is it gives you
this communication between the
JavaScript and the Python so when when
your going to change it on the
JavaScript it triggers a callback which
is sent to fight on and that calls this
function and when I do the same on five
hundred sends the message to JavaScript
which in turn changes the block so this
this isn't like bouquet where you write
JavaScript code and it does it after the
fact all of this is in Python and all
the communication is happening through
Python so what's up so it is it's right
now it's synchronous you could do it in
some closely but you don't want to get
into that nightmare with I mean until at
least people understand understand the
first biotech I mean it's already quite
a bit of a move so yeah so that's the
first big thing about be qbq plot the
JavaScript and the Python totally
communicate you you you don't have to
write any sort of JavaScript code to do
any of this okay the second thing is BQ
plot is like Gigi blah Gigi and Iggy
blood means grammar of graphics regret
grammar graphics is a way to compose a
to compose a plot from all the different
components so you look at the plot as
many different things a figure which is
the canvas you've been done you have
your axes which are the you know the
lines on the vertical the key thing in
the grammar of graphics is what's called
a scale the scale is a mapping function
from your data coordinates to pixel
coordinates so if your data runs from
zero to ten your pixels might run from
some range but it Maps the data from
zero to ten to a pixel so if if you
really wanted to get to the very low
levels of a chart there's a low level
API that
we I think best respect the grammar of
graphics out of any API I've seen so you
have a scale you can define a scale for
the X and the y you think your type of
visualization whether it's scatter align
whatever you define you do the
visualization you pass a set of scales
along with your data you specify an axis
so use specimen axis and you associate
that with the scale so this get axis
becomes a visual representation of the
scale then finally you put all of this
into a figure and you display that
figure and there you have it the same
plot so you could do the same thing with
the methyl live like interface or you
could have an actual you know a proper
composition if you want to run code
after you it also works with the ipython
dot display so you can do display of the
figure and it will do that then you
don't want it to be the last line of
your code they're still interacting
everything stolen directive it's it's
just two different ways to write the
same thing this is more in grey like
more low-level let's you kind of do more
complicated things the good thing is
your scales are not just X&Y your scales
can be anything size rotation skew to
scale is a mapping from data to some
attributes so here let's say it's a set
of color data safe you know times when
we bought ourselves at 0 1 0 for selling
1 for buying so what we can do is
instead of doing an X scale and linear
and ordinal scale we can get a color
scale so it's mapping the data to a set
of colors we create the color scale we
say maps to green or red and then we
associate that with the scatter chart
again and we pass the color data to the
scatter chart what's that going to do
it's going to color the scatter chart
based on a set of data so you can do
this with the Bob with the other
interface too but it's just a good kind
of going to it now if you want to put
multiple different types of plot under
the same kind of figure you need the
notion of a scale because they're going
to be sharing one of one or both the
scales so here imagine it being border
bar chart so say we created some new
data for it we create the bar chart you
see that we make it share the same
scales as the scatter so that it can
appear on the same figure without there
being inconsistency then all we do is we
change the marks on the figure and if
you scroll back up you have a you have a
plot which has both bars and a scatter
you can do that you can do the you can
do the same thing with by plot you just
need to do you need to follow the math
level if types index so instead of doing
DL just b LD that scatter you can do PL
d that bar right after and it's going to
it's going to print that for you so you
can do something like this never a good
idea to live code but but there you go
and you can let's let's give this no so
you see the scatter is there maybe the
other way around would happen better so
yeah the scatter still the line chart is
still there sorry and thus get bars are
right below it so yeah so yeah you do
you do always have the ability to
compound multiple figures directly like
this so the cool thing about by plot is
it's math blob live desk but it's not
it's I mean we we definitely took away
some things we did that didn't fit into
the paradigm or we thought were
complicated so yeah you can do a simple
line chart you can put a title we also
support the new data frame syntax so if
you want to do something like you know
plots if you have your price data over
here so it's some data frame if you want
to plot security one you just need to
pass the name of the column and do the
data syntax so this is from the new math
column that's going to do the same thing
for you with the scatter chart you can
do it across multiple different you
could do it across multiple different
attributes you just need to pass the
data and everything should be good
okay so EQ plot does a lot more do we
have a lot of innovative visualizations
so
essentially you can also you have
something called a market map which is
essentially you have some style map
which can have tooltips on it you can
change the color change the font style
change the way the title is displayed
you can pass groupings to this market
map so if you essentially if you have
all of this country data but you want to
group it by continent you just passed
the groups and it's going to group it by
that and you can pass through the data
to that so you can display anything you
want really in the tooltips directly in
the browser you can change the
attributes you yeah pretty much
a-all of the plots share a ton of things
you can color buy a certain amount of
data and you can you can have color axis
had supports pretty much all the basic
things you need from a thermo clotting
library we also have I think some of the
nicest geo plotting so you define a
scale so you have all of D trees
different scales and you you can have a
map which is interactive your map can
also I mean you can have if you pass a
dictionary to it you can have you know
coloring for different countries you can
change the resolution of the scale you
can pass specific data based coloring so
you can easily generate with eight lines
and a dark interactive glory lot with
the color axis associated with it you
can have different types of map
different types of math whether its
United States Europe it allows you to
select countries so if you you know you
can bind events like clicking just
select a country clicking to select a
state so you can build kind of
arbitrarily complicated things you can
also have tooltips and set the map so I
mean you can support bind any sort of
data you want to it no problem at all
all of this is in just these many lines
of code so that's that I think that's
kind of going back to why I learn
another language so I would say DQ plot
should be
I mean if you want to do interactions in
the notebook if you want to build
applications it provides really a simple
interface to do all of this so how does
it help you how does it help with with
building applications so we have to
extend the grammar of graphics a bit so
the traditional grammar graphics is to
compose a figure with a set of different
components so here we have to define
another notion which is called I mean we
need since we have interactions we have
to define another layer on the grammar
of graphics we call that the interaction
there so if you have a set of data once
you do your imports as you can see you
can define what's called an interval
selector so basically if you guys have
used d3 it's a way to select on your
data you can associate a callback to
that interval selector right there so
here we use the iPad widget which is
called HTML and we just pass an
additional layers of the interaction
layer to the to the figure and there you
go you have an interaction that
increases as you I mean basically moves
with the mouse and you see this Python
function is constantly aware of what
would be read you're interacting with so
as the figure changes you can do
different things with with your data we
have a bunch of different selectors
making these positions as well so the
way this one works is it's a novel one
going down shrinks it going up increases
it
clicking freezes double clicking fair
fixes so it's really a fast way to
interact with your data so like if you
have a lot of line charts and you want
to do a computation on it if you want to
move to it quickly yeah so you can just
pretty much just move quickly through
your data and since it's speaking to
itself and you put this selector on
there you may be able to select those
data points and do some computational
yes that's how we use it so typically we
use so say you wanted to look at say the
pca of a bunch of line charts over
here but you only wanted to do it at
this period so you have a set of line
chart lines and you basically as you're
moving this this is aware so this
function instead of just doing a print
good actually computer PCA and another
plot could be updated with your three
principal component analysis in several
components let's say so since this is
all on Python it's just an SK learn call
but you could do it on a sub interval
very quickly since this is actually
passing the sub interval to you that
they're interacting with so you could do
the same thing with an index selector
you you have it on dates you have
basically you have you can you can also
get the indices of your data if you
don't want the scale data you can get
the indices so you can easily do those
computations you have brushes multi
brushes I mean you have the whole gamut
of things that you want you can style
your interactions you can do whatever
basically you want here so the
interaction layer really adds kind of
the brush like a lasso no we do have a
last cell but the brushes the brushes
like when you increase the width you
know the kind of traditional like the
rugged killers under the curve if you
have neck selector or better yes if you
really want to get deep into it you can
have multiple multiple selectors and
this one's myself yes there you go now
multiple selectors you can fix them
change them do whatever you want send
someone mentioned the lasso you can
actually do the you can do freeform
shape selection and that gives you a
selection right there so you have all of
that you have fan zoom you can then zoom
do whatever you want with the line chart
you can also hand draw segment if you if
you do have a line chart you can you
know change the shape
you can can you know make it so let's
say this is my BNL curve let's just make
it really profitable very quickly you
know we you know those that those that
die see does it I see thing I know yes
there is so yes so all of them thumb
width so you can see on the five plot
thing when you do they come when you can
have a dual bar object if you have the
dual bar object actually there's a reset
button associated with it so you can use
click reset and it usually does that
what about how you said you can save it
as a PNG say we're doing something for
publications can you put it out as an
SVG PDF so so PNG is that main one we
have an export of SVG function that's
common data because nobody wanted it
before so we could bring it back then
just being just depends on what you're
observing if you're if you're observing
the scale then it's going to give you
the two and the two edges but if you're
observing the mark it's going to give
you the indexes on the mark in one of
your github demos of this as you're
going look through time people can
select on specific points and then to
plot a subplot yeah for that point if
you do an interval selection how does it
come out as two different entities come
out as two different objects so it sends
you back a list which is there do it's
either the start and end point if you're
observing the scale or it gives you a
list of the indexes in your data that
you're selecting so that comes back as
that comes back as a list yes some
people like to push things to the limit
will it warn you if you're trying to
have too many points too much
interactivity is too much of a burden
you can do that you can you can control
that it's all I mean ideally this is
just a framework for people to build
things on top of so if you if you want
to do things like that it's all in five
times
you plotted a million points so that's
that's that that's the problem this is
all SVG so if you see these are actually
every single one of these things is a
web element so so probably one of the
big things that one of the big things
that Boca has that we don't have is we'd
rely on SVG they rely on canvas so not
to say that we don't have canvas but the
interactivity is predictably lower on
canvas typically would be advice so yeah
so you see every single one of these is
a web element so you could modify it in
the web and that would change it doesn't
make sense about a million points but so
that's one of you warned yeah yeah so so
what we do is typically so what we what
we do is that we have canvas based stuff
for that so say you have a say it's
really a contour function and you don't
really want to you don't really want to
get into the headache of doing a million
points and then wait for this to run
okay you can plot the contour on canvas
this is the figure and then put a
scatter chart on top of it so that you
have the kind of you have something nice
but you also you have the interactivity
on the points so that's that's our
advice for doing interactivity with big
a lot of points yeah it's true you don't
want to visualize a million points
because you don't perceive more than a
hundred typically what is your
out-of-the-box upper limit depends
10,000 and we read them 10,000
successfully and we differently any more
than 1,000 it's not even worth picking
you don't see anything but yeah again
you should do the in that case do it as
a heat map and then put you know boot
decay means as scatters and let them
interact with the cluster or do the data
and estimation with Python side that's
our advice okay so we have an
interaction layer but we also have
another level of interaction which is
called Mark interactions or each mark
each type of plot that you have allows
you to have a set of interactions so so
if you see here if you have
scatter chart essentially when you click
on a point you can select it and you can
define styles so they're selected and
for the unselected so here if you I mean
if you click you can select multiple you
can deselect one you can do pretty much
whatever you want and that changes an
attribute of your selected soon as I
select please select multiple let's say
that's going to make scatter chart I've
selected something else you can also
change that from the pipe inside so
they're both listening to each other
can also have tooltips so if you have
two different scatter charts you can
have two different tooltips those
tooltips can be any widget that you want
you don't want to do this to the general
use case but the point is that you can
we also listen to a bunch of other
events you can listen to events like on
hover on legend click on background
click and bind them find a function to
them here we find that function print
event so we we have four different
listeners now so you may have a
background click we have an event
element click we have a legend click I
think yep so it's telling you which
event is being called so you can listen
to that and change your function
according to what you're doing or buying
different functions to every one of them
the cool thing is every figure is a
every figure is actually a widget so
what that means is that if you a we need
someone yes if you click you can put a
plot directly as a tooltip so if you
want to visualize data very quickly you
can do that kind of really simply it's
no problem at all can do the same with
every different type of chart you can
may do it on a legend click basically
all of these things are kind of a
uniform API even in the bars you can
select any one of the bars so imagine if
you're plotting a set of des terrors or
trainers or model weights you can click
on one and then drill down and do it
through selections yes so pretty moming
if you look at histograms you can do
this
you can have tooltips on each one you
can do pretty much whatever you want to
all of the interactions are going to
plug in playable you have a pie chart
you can you know click and do a build
upon that you can change the opacity I
don't know why you would want to but I
mean it's just to say that it's kind of
freeform right now we we have a lot of
different marks so the different charts
and I think constitute a mark and you
know we have candles we have a flex line
we have histograms labels by charge
scatter charts I think we cover pretty
much all the basic use cases to that
Network yeah that's that's something
that we have a pull request for me we
haven't done much Cydia if you want to
do dad's stuff good luck with you good
love but it's yeah but we have thought
about networks but in general I have to
say I don't find networks like if you
get them so bored and stuff and I don't
find a network visualizations helpful I
think they could be more helpful good
selection so if you click on a specific
node you can monitor its way through
time to monitor its gradients you can do
things like that but I mean I've never
found them to be particularly effective
but that's personal bias um John yes
there are there let's let's go to this
example so now I'm going to get a walk
through how we built an application in
it and we're going to see how I fire
widgets provide layout tools that let
you do that
so so ok so here how many people know
the wealth of nations example the
showmance plenty of people okay so
wealth of nations is Hans Rosling bless
his soul his one of his most famous
examples so we're going to look at how
we recreate that in BQ plot so just to
start being for different things like
colors figures labels we start at 1800
we keep the data so the data is a very
complicated JSON file so I'm going to
clean the data
we're going to extrapolate and
interpolate it and we're going to you
know we're going to define a callback
that gets the data for you so on PQ plot
side the first thing we do is we define
a dual set the fuels we care about are
the name the X and the y and we're going
to label them country income per capita
and life expectancy that's historically
the x and y and the name of the country
we're going to define a label we're
going to position it at X at the bottom
left corner the bottom right corner just
just to mimic my postdocs kind of
original one you can move labels so it's
okay we're defining a font and the text
of it here we define the different
scales remember the x axis of welcome
nations is a log scale because either if
it grows kind of quickly we define a set
of axes and we get the data for the
initial year and what we're going to do
is a scatter chart where we set a set of
things we give it tool tip a scholar
scale and yeah finally the color is by
the way the region so if I mean that's
historically how it's done also we
define a line so we're going to show you
what the line does finally we create the
figure and okay so now the wizard is the
thing that makes BQ plot really cool is
it plays with the ipython native widgets
so here we play with with with an in
slider so that comes directly from hi
widgets so the in slider is just it's
just another widget but actually what it
is is another JavaScript object that's
in sync that's a your slider that you
can when you pull it we're going to
create a callback for the hover and a
callback for when you move this slider
so you observe in the scatter you over
observe the hovered point and on the
slider you observe the value so
basically when they change the value by
moving it around you want to call the
function your changed and finally you
add an animation button which is another
iPad widget thing and you just link
whenever you click Play pause you just
move the slider and that slider callback
is going to deal with everything on on
for the visualization side so for
layouts we have h box and V box object
so when you put an h box putting two
things horizontally so if you put two
figures in an h box that's through
horizontal figures a V box puts it
vertically so you have two horizontal
things with a vertical figure so you
could have multiple V boxes and H boxes
to create a kind of complicated layouts
so when you do that you get something
like this you get the initial wealth of
nations so if you move this slider
you see that's going to move slowly over
time the scatter plot moves if you hover
over any point you see the entire path
of the country and the current value you
can always hit play and then you just
get an animation you can it's not so
jumpy when it's on a nice computer you
can pause it play it do I mean smooth
out the animations hover on it life do
pretty much whatever you want actually
and it's a no problem at all
yes but you forgive my computer is very
slow JavaScript but yeah essentially you
can you can hover over the path you can
hover over the country you can do pretty
much whatever you want
finish the play it's going to run
through all of the different countries
and then you see other thing is evolving
so it's really simple to do this well
defends and the play won't go backwards
because the plays guide to this but you
could reverse the value of this slider
and then do the backwards thing if you
do that with code though you can move
this slider if you want to go backwards
but yeah you can do that with code yes
so different ways we use it a recent
example is people use denser board it's
not very customizable the cool thing
about this you plot is it is custom
you don't need to do much so you have a
kind of stand let's say kind of a
standard problem so let let's do this
with Karis but any library that supports
callbacks or if you're using flies or if
you're going through their training box
you can change because odd things so the
first thing you can do is just visualize
m-miss so you can create a drop-down
here so all of this code is on github by
the way this is a full request but it
should be merged in the next week
or you can just download the notebook
both of us don't really mean anything in
that regard so you have a drop-down that
says whether you're on your trainer desk
and you have an in slider over the
entire shape and pretty much when you
move the heat inside all you do is
change the color of your canvas basic
map so it's effectively an image
rendering so we're just that little bit
of code goes faster you can just change
you can change the amnesty the
JavaScript research public clothes all
the piece things
sorry about that so yeah so once I close
all of these notebooks my in Intel
Pentium dual start start start
responding to all of this yes so
basically as you slide you see the you
can visualize the different elements of
the amnesty really quickly it's no
problem at all
alternatively you can define a callback
so for people who use Garth's super
simple just create your figures create
your dashboard on the in it and update
it on each each box and just evaluate
your function and shouldn't be a problem
at all so here we can you know visualize
really let's take
so essentially lets you visualize I let
you create the it creates all of these
different it creates this dashboard for
you and when my computer decides to run
an e-book you'll see that that the train
and desk there is actually update live
as you go along so essentially it's it's
a version of dance aboard in your
notebook without any sort of without any
hassles or anything like that
we should another the problem is I'm
gonna actually stop running them for it
yeah I don't want to kill the no network
one where I won't kill everything else
let's hope that work um yeah so that's
that's pretty much the idea of the
cupola with a adapt changes and you
essentially one re button or M list on
logical is it Python three and it works
for both by thank you entry right now
I'll wait till is three six three five I
don't think we were country six yet yeah
this this is not looking good for my
computer ah problems of a live demo
events he and update it's going to be
awesome there's a promise all these are
demo in a super notebook there's the
scripts off from the last month they do
jupiter lab is coming out is disick
naturally move into that
so that's news so i actually so in my
dream scenario i would have access to
the Wi-Fi wouldn't be doing it locally
I'd be doing it on my remote computers
which are faster and have you been a lab
on them that it doesn't work yet I know
bloom dude only works on Windows and Mac
so far
the cool thing is yes so the best thing
or a bigger plot is going to be that it
works fully with with the dubidouxs lab
when you so I don't know if Carol showed
you then Jupiter lab you can drag the
output or different Deb bq+ is listening
to those events so when you create a
layout and bake you plot and you resize
the figures automatically going to
resize to take up the entire space so
it's entirely B cube lot of design be
one of my teammates that jason Grodd
actually the lead developer so we were
working hard to make sure we keep a lot
of the first library that works
completely in Jupiter lab if you were to
build something like this on a useful
computer you could you can move the
entire output cell to a different tab
and continue coding while monitoring the
dashboard and the mirrored output would
handle that any other Krishna can you
communicate the the cross hold on vital
users and keep the functionality unlike
similar like an owl markdown render it
yes so all of so a couple of things yeah
so there's two levels of portability for
BQ plus one is actually a one is
actually boarding it as JavaScript code
so right now we render on nbb or after
because maybe the first time I just say
yeah so here you see we have a train and
desk chart that's going to move across
them and I'm sure for the first three
epochs but for each epoch it's updating
so are the average l1 norm waged by
layers so essentially you want to see if
your weights are concentrated in the
start of your network or at the end of
your network and typically you see that
weights that are concentrated at the
start then to general as better so you
might want to do so here it's it's
pretty simple smooth way to build a
dashboard inside uh inside a notebook
for your training and Dustin you can
visualize different things you can do a
heat map for the gradients you can do
pretty much whatever you want to so it's
super simple so about the exporting
thing there's two ways to export it yes
I want to save as PNG right now okay the
cool thing right
now is that there is a way so if you
want to embed this just as JavaScript
you just need to go to widgets embed
widgets that's going to generate all of
the JavaScript code for you you can just
paste that into an HTML file and it's
like a web page if you env convert
supports that right now and be converted
so if you do save this notebook with
embedded widgets it's going to save this
final block for you so if you go do I
don't actually have internet
unfortunately um with the interactivity
embedded in the JavaScript side right
now yeah if you have a Python callback
that's doing the interactivity you you
can do it but there is effort so we
should have that and once we do it's
just a question you could just export
this as an application directly from the
notebook right now you need it you need
a browser I mean you need the browser to
do the web stuff right we we don't know
whether we want to support just doing a
Python you know just you run Python on a
script and it generates it for you
because we going to build this for the
notebook but I mean we imagine that we
will at some point to do that is
probably so something yes it's just all
the JavaScript interactive get more done
yeah because I mean you see here it's
calling the kernel these things are all
life I mean in an interactive Python
session so what we do so far is kind of
in Jupiter lab we just take the
application make it a separate outfit
cell like we just drag it to another to
have and let people use it as an
application there and so right now if
you have a Geo JSON you facet and a all
of your objects inside the Geo JSON are
available to you on the Python side like
in the sense that you can be made aware
of which ones are selected which ones
are unselected which one is being
hovered over so I mean it as soon as you
pass a G or JSON but we're constantly
fill
more and more grj sons into it I mean
it's just any geodata
so it doesn't there's no notion of a
template another like what you said it
goes over all the attributes that's so
it's going so in if there's one dicey
thing if you have imagine if you if in
the d3 than 110 maps and stuff you see
that actually there are two attributes
one is each of the countries and then
there's one which is the entire planet
as a single thing so if you do something
like that then it's going to just do all
of the you know it's going to put that
entire map on top of the country so it's
going to be useless but as long as
they're goj so it makes sense it's going
to cycle over the different kings things
should be okay
well when you send the very beginning of
the presentation there's lots of these
graphs and libraries that are coming out
and one of the newer ones I've seen is
plotly which allows you to do a lot of
the interactivity but they do this they
enable you to save things as HTML
objects and add them in like PowerPoint
presentation yeah
do you guys see that support coming like
you said you have this SVG commented out
but do you have do you see that support
coming to be to plot to allow all these
different types of exporting yeah I mean
we just never had someone requested and
particularly doing I mean I'm sure we
will look into that I don't know how far
they work so if you see you've seen our
IBM you see in there hi how does it
compare there's this d3 base too so they
have their own advertisements like logo
does and you know what work to get it to
run either offline yeah or online
because they have the Jupiter notebook
extensibility in there like in a work of
the Jupiter notebook but if you want to
use things really high-end exported
SVG's you have to have an API key in the
membership because they do their that
their service involvement so we're we're
fully oh do things were fully open
source and it's no you just do ganda
install for us from Ghana Forge and it's
off the ground Ernest there's no problem
on that end for us Fei wise I think we
still pretty much cleaner
those from the blog Leon see that's why
this is very promising because more
plotly as a business they really make
their stuff look a little bit more
clean-cut as far as the marketability of
it so to speak but here there's a lot of
promise for this interactivity for the
basic on-the-ground researcher like I'm
in academia so if I want to put this I
do some lab work and I want to do it in
the presentation this is extremely
promising to me but if we want to put it
like a snapshot of our data we would
want something like an SVG which is
easily you can put it easily into a PDF
or a document that's like the only thing
that I see that I'm like wow so yes I
mean that again you could just see and
maybe the uncommon to code might not
work but I mean you always it's totally
open source everything then get up so we
welcome any contributions for things you
guys need any other questions yes
buttons yeah yeah easily yeah yeah so
you just need to do
yep no problem at all
that's a button and you can you can do
3d buttons
radio buttons dogle buttons whatever you
want so I'm risking it but but let's see
that hacking code it's going to work do
you just do you just find that okay yeah
that's to display that button all day
yeah yeah so you just every time you
click it you can change everything
yeah you can show the edges this upset
you want everything is changeable now we
this was before you even started how
does this claim of Gans III was just I
so my team my team that was just out to
my dad's kind of independently I mean
you could use this to train so you could
build a dashboard with it it's no
problem but my team is actually the
quantitative research team me we just
happen to build this to make our lives
easier actually so it kind of came out
authentically motivated by data science
and want work that was just document
event earlier about that yes I don't
know if I have internet access probably
not I'm guessing not yes
I'm making all of this is all of this
all of these are examples on our github
repo everything that I've shown so sure
sure no problem
brush yeah no problem at all
we do it all the time you and I wish I
could show an example of it but no
internet we do a thing where we we have
scatter plots of repent I mean our time
series so say have a price if you want
to fit a trend line just on the interval
you just fit a trend line and show you
the slope of the line so it's super
simple
so like math omelet I guess you have
these artists and you can like go in and
change very specific attributes of them
how's that compare so every week you
plot mark that seems and are roughly the
same as an artist has a bunch of
properties we can change those
arbitrarily some of them expose the CSS
directly so they'll take in a dictionary
where you pass the key and the value and
those are CSS keys and values so they're
really low level changes and remember if
if there's anything you want to do
that's really high five CSS which you
don't know how to do it's still a web
element you can always just do from
ipython import CSS select that element
and force I mean kind of something very
complicated if you absolutely have to
they're all life so are there any
alternative language support language
api's like our where it's an event for
bq+
big not I mean the problem there is I
bike on and I beverages don't support
any language except icon right now if
they do it's it's just a few I mean it's
just it's a simple two together video
guys
if there are no more questions just
again I'd like to remind everybody tweet
at us if you want to grab one of those
free books also on your way out are
going to grab some extra sandwiches you
guys done left over to help yourselves
bring them home to loved one and helped
me in thinking group again feel free to
hang around maybe 15 minutes longer if
you want to network a little bit and
then I'll be head out before you